we turn now to a health issue many
americans can relate to nearly two years
into the pandemic covert restrictions
have kept many people indoors making it
difficult to lead an active healthy
lifestyle and that is creating problems
for doctors that extend far beyond the
virus this morning as part of our
american heart month coverage dr tara
narula introduces us to a man who's
turning his life around after a scary
life-threatening diagnosis a pulmonary
embolism
with every step benjamin henderson is on
a path to a healthier life i can't push
myself yet but my exercise is walking
i do a lot of walking right here in the
park
the 56 year old henderson is lucky to be
moving at all a little more than two
months ago he almost lost his life
i got dressed to go to the store and as
soon as this elevator came up i got on
as soon as the door closed
i went into a pant
he got himself back upstairs and called
his cousin
my cousin he helped me to the bed when i
woke up again it was 1 30 in the morning
my stomach and my chest was tight felt
like a knot so i came out and i told my
cousin i said we have to go to the
hospital so you started having symptoms
around three o'clock in the afternoon
three pm yes ma'am when did you call ems
called the mls about 1 30 in the morning
so you waited 11 hours 11 hours yes
ma'am what did that do to his chances of
survival
by not seeking care immediately he was
lucky omar letouf is henderson's
cardiovascular surgeon within 30 minutes
of meeting his patient he was ready to
operate i think if he had waited any
longer he would have died
i think he could have gone to sleep and
never woken up henderson had a pulmonary
embolism a dangerous blood clot that
often starts in the leg and travels
through the heart to the lungs a large
clot blocks blood flow causing the right
side of the heart to fail as it tries to
pump against the massive blockage in
certain cases this can lead to cardiac
arrest and possibly death
smaller emboli could be treated with
medication but in this case dr letouf
knew he had to operate and when you
opened up his pulmonary arteries and saw
the extent of the clot was it larger
than you had anticipated how does it
compare
relatives it was quite large it was
almost
16 inches long by the time we pulled the
whole thing out when you see in a cloth
that's that big what is the potential
for survival for a patient who does not
have treatment not very good
latuff says several factors put
henderson at risk including obesity and
a sedentary lifestyle henderson had
spent the better part of four years
caring for his mother who suffered from
dementia he says during that time he
ignored his own health dr la two told me
that because of lack of exercise
because of my diet because of obesity
and that's where the blood clots came
from it sounds like you're a bit of a
miracle
i feel that way
since being released from the hospital
in mid-december henderson has lost more
than 40 pounds and dr letouf says he's
encouraged by the progress what do you
think it was that saved you i'm
spiritual and my mother just passed away
seven months ago and i took care of
dude
i took care of from
almost four years five years
and um
i was a caregiver and everything
and i do believe that she was holding my
hand the whole way
you know i have a tendency scar in my
chest
that's a total reminder that uh i have
to take care of myself i have a second
chance at life
dr tara narula joins us right now so
what are some of the risk factors for
pulmonary embolism well i'm so glad you
asked because this is actually the third
leading cause of cardiovascular death
after heart attack and stroke which we
don't often talk about
and it can happen to anyone at any stage
so risk factors include things like bed
rest or long plane flights or car rides
more than four hours obesity smoking
certain hormone therapy like oral
contraceptives hormone replacement
therapy pregnancy cancer or cancer
treatments um and major hospitalization
like major prolonged hospitalizations or
major surgeries any of those things can
increase your risk and then finally
genetic conditions so some people have a
family history of clotting it's really
important to know that because you may
have a predisposition to clotting
disorders it's very scary what about
symptoms if if you're worried right so
also important because left untreated
there's a 30 mortality with pulmonary
embolism so with pulmonary embolism
we're talking about shortness of breath
chest pain that we say is pleuritic
meaning it's worse when you take a deep
breath in
some people feel a rapid heart rate and
may cough up some blood-tinged or pink
sputum and then as far as clots in the
legs we're talking about red swollen
tender painful legs usually one leg
so recognizing symptoms is really
critical and don't ignore this no please
these are these are very important to
get checked out immediately dr narula
you're the best thank you so much